I know so many people who have films that they have watched over and over, and I have never really gotten that. I always feel like there are so many films that I haven't seen, why would I watch one again? But we get into these conversations. And there always comes a moment where I'm asked, well, what is the film that you've seen the most?
我认识很多人，他们都有看过无数遍的电影，但我从来没法理解那种感觉。我总觉得还有那么多没看过的电影，为什么要把一部电影看第二遍呢？但我们还是会聊到这些话题。而且总有那么一刻，会被人问到：那么，你看过次数最多的电影是什么？
And then I have to admit, it's The Poseidon Adventure, which I know is not a good film. It's this '70s movie about an ocean liner that gets hit by a tsunami, flips upside down, and the passengers try to make their way to safety. It's part of an entire genre of films, disaster films, that have never gotten any respect. Nobody thinks of these films as art. But I loved it at the time when I saw it. It felt big, and it felt important and serious. And I remember it was very emotional.
然后我就不得不承认，是《海神号遇险记》。我知道那不是一部好电影。这是一部70年代的电影，讲述了一艘远洋客轮被海啸击中，翻转倒扣，乘客们试图逃生的故事。它属于灾难片这一整个不受待见的类型。没人把这些电影当作艺术。但当年我看的时候很喜欢它。它感觉很宏大，很重要，很严肃。而且我记得它非常感人。
And the reason that I saw it so many times, that this is the film that I saw more than any other, was not because I loved the film. It's because of where I saw it. I was on vacation. We didn't take many vacations when I was a kid, but on one of them, we stayed at this hotel in Florida where the rooms had this thing where they offered a couple of movies all day long. And this was so long ago in the 1970s. My sisters and I, we had never seen anything like that. Even cable TV was rare back then. The Poseidon Adventure was the film that they offered. And my sister, Karen, and I we ate it up.
我之所以看过那么多次，之所以它是我就看得最多的电影，并不是因为我有多爱它。而是因为我当时是在哪里看的。我在度假。我小时候很少去度假，但有一次，我们住在佛罗里达的一家酒店里，那里的房间提供全天候轮播的几部电影。那是在70年代，是很久以前的事了。我和我的姐妹们以前从未见过那种东西。那时连有线电视都很罕见。《海神号遇险记》就是他们提供的电影。我和我姐姐卡伦，我们看了个没完。
That was the movie we watched over and over again, yeah.
那是我们反复看的那部电影，没错。
Oh, so this was a very important movie.
哦，所以这真是一部很重要的电影。
That's Karen and her son, Zach, my nephew, who we tried to explain this to recently.
那是卡伦和她的儿子扎克，我的侄子，我们最近试图向他解释这件事。
So we ended up watching it on TV at night, if our parents went out to dinner, or if it was a rainy day. Yeah, we loved it.
所以我们最后会在晚上，如果父母出去吃晚饭，或者下雨天的时候，就在电视上看它。是的，我们很喜欢它。
The way that I remember it is that the hotel just had this movie on a loop. And it would just, as soon as it would finish, it would start again. And the way I remember it is that every time we would come into the hotel room, you could turn on the TV, and you'd be somewhere in The Poseidon Adventure.
我的记忆是，酒店就在循环播放这部电影。它一放完，马上又会重新开始。我的记忆是，每次我们走进酒店房间，打开电视，你总能看到《海神号遇险记》的某个片段。
That sounds vaguely familiar to me. I don't totally remember that, but that might be right, yeah.
这听起来有点耳熟。我记得不是很清楚，但可能是那样，没错。
And I remember it having a lot of feeling. Do you remember it having a lot of feeling?
我记得它很有感染力。你记得它很有感染力吗？
What does that mean, having a lot of feeling? Like, eliciting--
什么叫“很有感染力”？是指引发……
I remember feeling a lot of emotions.
我记得那里面充满情感。
Yeah, well, it's scary. And you're really invested in their journey to escape alive. I don't think I'm giving anything away by saying that.
是的，很吓人。而且你会真正投入到他们拼死逃生的旅程中。我不觉得说出这一点是在剧透。
Sort of are.
某种程度上算是吧。
Here at the radio show these last few weeks, we've been talking about the random films that people have strong attachments to, thinking that might be a good episode of the show. And I started to think about The Poseidon Adventure. And I wondered what it would be like to see it again. Would it have any feeling? Would any of it feel the way it did to me as a kid? Would it feel that way to Karen?
过去几周在电台节目中，我们一直在谈论人们强烈依恋的那些随机电影，觉得这可能会是一期很棒的节目。我开始想到《海神号遇险记》。我想知道再看一遍会是什么感觉。它还会有感染力吗？里面的任何情节还会像我小时候感觉的那样吗？卡伦也会有那种感觉吗？
So my sister and I, we watched it. And I invited Zach too, since he's the age that we were when we watched it back in the '70s. He's 13. I was 14 at the time. Karen was 11. And I want to say, I did not expect Zach to like it. He does not like a lot of films.
所以我和我姐姐看了这部电影。我也邀请了扎克，因为他现在的年纪和我们当年看电影时的年纪一样。他13岁。我当时14岁。卡伦11岁。我想说，我没指望扎克会喜欢它。他不喜欢很多电影。
And right away, the very first scene let us know the kind of film we were in for. A little boy visits the bridge of the SS Poseidon, this ocean liner in the middle of a big storm. And the little boy is greeted by the captain, who's played by Leslie Nielsen-- who, at this point, had not made the career transition to parodying characters like this captain.
从一开始，第一个场景就让我们知道这会是什么样的电影。一个小男孩参观“波塞冬号”的驾驶台，这是一艘在大风暴中的远洋客轮。小男孩受到了船长的欢迎，船长由莱斯利·尼尔森饰演——当时他还没有转型去演像这位船长这样角色的恶搞片。
Mr. Shelby, you've picked a particularly fascinating moment to accept my invitation. These waves don't bother you, huh?
谢尔比先生，你选择了一个非常迷人的时刻来接受我的邀请。这些海浪没有困扰你吧？
I've surfed up to 18 feet, but these look more like 30.
我冲过18英尺高的浪，但这些看起来更像是30英尺。
35, to be exact.
准确说是35英尺。
Wow, surf's really up.
哇，浪真的很大。
Oh, my.
哦，天哪。
What's "oh, my"?
什么叫“哦，天哪”？
Those lines. So cheesy.
那些台词。太老套了。
I didn't remember how wincey the acting got in some places. When Ernest Borgnine shows up, it's clear that the 1956 Oscar winner for Best Actor is not in one of his best roles.
我不记得有些地方的表演竟然这么让人尴尬。当欧内斯特·博格宁出现时，很明显这位1956年的奥斯卡影帝并不在他的最佳状态。
Linda, you hear me
琳达，你听见我说话吗？
Why is he so angry?
为什么他那么生气？
Borgnine does seem to shout nearly every one of his lines in the film. One thing that kind of stunned me and I did not expect, seeing the film again, was how much of the dialogue I remember from decades ago. And I was also surprised to realize-- and I do not know what this says about me-- the lines that I remember the most are the little comic zingers, like when a crew member is asked if he's married, I know his corny response before he says it.
博格宁在电影里几乎每句台词都是喊出来的。让我震惊且意想不到的是，再看一遍电影，我竟然记得几十年前的大部分对白。我还惊讶地意识到——我不知道这说明了我什么——我记得最清楚的台词是那些小幽默，比如当船员被问到是否结婚时，他在回答之前我就知道他的那个老套回应了。
No marriage for me, Mrs. Rosen. I've got a mistress.
我没结婚，罗森太太。我有个情人。
What?
什么？
The sea.
大海。
Hey, that's good.
嘿，那说得好。
Something I did remember, and remember liking from the film, was that this was an old-fashioned enough movie that the producers tried to insert some big ideas into the adventure, so it would all mean something. These big ideas are provided by Gene Hackman, who plays a rebellious young priest in a turtleneck, whose big theological idea is a very conveniently helpful one for people who are about to be capsized in the middle of the ocean. God doesn't want you to wait for miracles. You have to take matters into your own hands.
我记得并喜欢这部电影的一点是，它是一部足够老派的电影，制片人试图在冒险中加入一些宏大的思想，让这一切变得有意义。这些宏大的思想由吉恩·哈克曼提供，他扮演了一位穿着高领毛衣的叛逆年轻牧师，他最大的神学理念对于那些即将在大洋中央翻船的人来说非常方便：上帝不希望你等待奇迹。你必须把命运掌握在自己手中。
Don't pray to God to solve your problems.
不要祈求上帝解决你的问题。
This is from a sermon he delivers early in the film.
这是他在电影早期布道时说的话。
Have the guts to fight for yourself. God wants brave souls. He wants winners, not quitters. If you can't win, at least try to win.
要有勇气为自己而战。上帝想要勇敢的灵魂。他想要赢家，而不是逃兵。如果你不能赢，至少也要试着去赢。
He comes back to this over and over through the film, rallying the passengers to fight on. I loved that as a teenager, that there was this idealistic guy with this principle that he's trying to live by and this idea about God that the film is testing. And I have to say, seeing it today, I still loved it, that they put that in there. Anyway, soon enough, right at the stroke of midnight on New Year's Eve, the tsunami hits, the boat flips, the plot line tips.
他在电影中反复提到这一点，号召乘客们奋力抗争。我十几岁的时候很喜欢这一点，有一个怀揣着这种原则并努力实践的理想主义者，以及电影在考验这种关于上帝的理念。我必须说，今天再看一遍，我依然喜欢他们把这些加进去。总之，不久之后，就在除夕午夜时分，海啸袭来，船翻了，剧情也随之倒转。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫]
In the wreckage of the upside down New Year's party, Gene Hackman convinces only eight passengers that they shouldn't stay and wait for God to send rescuers, but climb with him to safety.
在翻倒的新年派对残骸中，吉恩·哈克曼只说服了八名乘客，让他们不要留下来等待上帝派遣救援，而是跟随他攀爬去寻找生路。
Now, please, for God's sake, come with me.
求求你们，看在上帝的份上，跟我来。
They creep from deck to deck, barely escaping the rising water as they go. The ceilings of the rooms are the floors that they walk on, and the floors are the ceilings. There's a fiery upside-down kitchen. They go up slippery ladders and inverted staircases. And by the time they start dying, one by one, for Karen and me and even Zach, it's no joke. We're in it. We care.
他们从一层甲板爬到另一层，惊险地躲过不断上涨的积水。房间的天花板变成了他们行走的地面，而地面变成了天花板。有一个火光冲天的倒置厨房。他们爬上湿滑的梯子和颠倒的楼梯。当他们开始一个接一个死去时，对卡伦、我甚至扎克来说，这都不是玩笑。我们全身心投入了。我们在乎。
[GROANING]
[呻吟]
[SPLASHING]
[水花声]
Did she just have a heart attack? Wait, did she just have a heart attack?
她刚才是不是心脏病发作了？等等，她刚才心脏病发作了吗？
Yes.
是的。
Wow. That's a pretty random heart attack.
哇。那心脏病发作得太突然了。
Not really. Think about the fact that she just did all that swimming and she's out of shape.
其实不然。想想她刚才游了那么久，而且她身体素质本来就不太好。
After Mrs. Rosen, the menschy grandma in the film dies. Her husband discovers her dead body.
在罗森太太——电影里那位热心的祖母——去世后，她的丈夫发现了她的尸体。
Oh, that guy is going to be so sad.
哦，那个家伙会很难过的。
I remember this moment so well.
这一刻我记得太清楚了。
I remember this too, really well. This was very affecting.
我也记得这一幕，记得很清楚。这非常感人。
I've been really invested in this movie. It's sort of good.
我真的完全被这部电影吸引住了。它还挺不错的。
You do feel very invested?
你真的感到很投入吗？
Yeah, it's like I'm not sure what's going to happen next, unlike most other movies.
是啊，不像大多数电影，我甚至不确定接下来会发生什么。
I'd wondered if Zach was going to feel the same big feelings that I felt for the film at his age. And he totally did.
我曾想过扎克是否会像我当年那样对这部电影有同样强烈的感受。他确实如此。
[SCREAMING]
[尖叫]
Wow, she dies?
哇，她死了？
Linda!
琳达！
No. Oh, he dies, too? No.
不。哦，他也死了？不。
Linda!
琳达！
They were so close.
他们离得那么近。
Linda! Linda!
琳达！琳达！
No.
不。
Linda!
琳达！
By the time we get to Gene Hackman's big climactic speech to God--
当听到吉恩·哈克曼对上帝的那段高潮演讲时——
What more do you want of us? We've come all this way, no thanks to you.
你还想从我们这儿得到什么？我们历经千辛万苦才走到这里，这可一点都没多亏你。
--it was clear The Poseidon Adventure, it does its job. It gets to you. But thinking about the experience that Zach had watching the film and the one that I was having, it's so different, right? For me, it was like walking into a room from my childhood home and finding it intact and exactly how I remembered it. Or we would get to a scene and I would remember things I didn't realize I remembered. Is there even a name for that?
——很明显《海神号遇险记》完成了它的使命。它确实打动了你。但想到扎克观看这部电影的体验和我正在进行的体验，真的很不同，对吧？对我来说，这就像走进童年时代家里的一个房间，发现它完好无损，和我记忆中一模一样。又或者我们会看到某个场景，我会记起那些我以前没意识到自己还记得的事情。这甚至有名字吗？
When we watch a movie together, we think we're watching the same thing, but we are not. For me, The Poseidon Adventure is a portal back to that vacation and being in that hotel room with Karen and knowing those movie stars from other things they made and just that whole time in my life. I can't show Zach that movie.
当我们一起看电影时，我们以为我们在看同一个东西，但其实不然。对我而言，《海神号遇险记》是一个传送门，把我带回了那次度假，带回了和卡伦在酒店房间里的时光，带回了对那些电影明星在其他作品中角色的认知，以及我生命中的那段时期。我无法向扎克展示那部电影（真实的体验）。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, we're at a point in the pandemic where so many of us are still not going out to movie theaters. And we thought, here at our show, let's do a movie night. Let's do a show about movies. And in particular, we decided to get people who have watched a film over and over, who see something in it that most people do not see, films for which they are an audience of one. These are stories about how we connect to films sometimes very deeply, but sometimes in very strange and random ways. Stay with us.
这里是WBEZ芝加哥电台，《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目中，疫情期间我们很多人仍然不去电影院。我们想，在我们的节目里，不如举办一场电影之夜。让我们做一期关于电影的节目。特别是，我们决定邀请那些反复观看同一部电影的人，那些在电影中看到了大多数人看不到的东西的人，那些对他们来说是“唯一的观众”的电影。这些故事讲述了我们有时如何与电影建立深刻的联系，但有时又是以非常奇怪和随机的方式。请继续收听。
Act One, "Many a Thing She Ought to Understand." One of our producers, Diane Wu, spent most of her life thinking that she did not have a unique and personal take on the film The Sound of Music. The Sound of Music-- after all, everybody loves it. What's there to say? And then she learned, no, her take is very different.
第一幕，“她本该理解的许多事”。我们的制作人之一戴安·吴，大半辈子都认为她对电影《音乐之声》没有独特的个人看法。《音乐之声》——毕竟大家都喜欢它。还有什么好说的呢？然后她发现，不，她的看法非常不同。
I watched The Sound of Music all the time as a kid. It was one of maybe six VHS tapes we had at home, along with Bambi and 101 Dalmatians. And a few years ago, I was talking with a friend about how much I loved the movie growing up. And he said, me too, though the Nazis scared me. And I said, what Nazis?
小时候我经常看《音乐之声》。这是我们家仅有的六盘录像带之一，还有《小鹿斑比》和《101忠狗》。几年前，我和一个朋友聊到我成长过程中有多喜欢这部电影。他说，我也是，虽然纳粹让我很害怕。我说，什么纳粹？
And that's when I learned I'd never seen the second half of the film. It turns out the movie came out in a two VHS box set. And I, for some reason, had only ever seen the first tape. My dad doesn't remember a second tape either. And why would you need one? The first half makes perfect sense on its own.
也就是那时我才发现，我从来没看过电影的后半部分。原来这部电影是以两盘录像带的套装形式发行的。不知何故，我一直只看过第一盘。我爸爸也不记得有第二盘。而且为什么要两盘呢？第一部分本身就非常完整了。
Here's the plot. It's a movie about a woman named Maria, who is sent to the countryside to babysit a giant family of children with a mean dad, the von Trapps. Maria shows up, bubbly, fun, and teaches them to sing and play and be kids, all against the wishes of their father. But the singing wins him over. They sing together as a family. And finally, at a party, the kids sing a beautiful song for the guests. Farewell. And after that, Maria, having successfully fixed the family, leaves, just like Mary Poppins did when she fixed that family. And that's the end of the movie.
剧情是这样的。电影讲的是一个叫玛丽亚的女人，被派往乡村去照看一个拥有严厉父亲的大家庭——冯·特拉普家。玛丽亚来了，活泼有趣，教他们唱歌、玩耍，做一个孩子，所有这一切都违背了他们父亲的意愿。但歌声赢得了他的心。他们像一家人一样唱歌。最后，在一次派对上，孩子们为客人们唱了一首美丽的歌，《再见》。在那之后，玛丽亚圆满地修复了这个家庭，离开了，就像朱莉·安德鲁斯演的玛丽·波平斯修复那个家庭一样。这就是电影的结局。
I had very clear fond memories of the goatherd puppet show and the scene in the gazebo where Liesl, the eldest daughter, secretly met with the mailman she was in love with. And they sang and danced, and it was so romantic. I had no further questions about any of the characters. So when I learned that there were 70 more minutes to the film, I didn't bother going to look for them. The Sound of Music was a full complete and wonderful artifact from my childhood. I didn't want to taint it with Nazis.
我对牧羊人木偶戏和凉亭里的场景记忆犹新，那是大女儿丽莎偷偷和她爱上的邮差见面的地方。他们唱歌跳舞，非常浪漫。我对任何角色都没有疑问了。所以当我得知电影还有70分钟的时候，我并没有费心去找来看。《音乐之声》是我童年里一件完整而美好的纪念品。我不想让纳粹玷污它。
But when my co-worker, Lina, who's producing this week's show and is a musical theater fan-- which I most definitely am not-- when she found out I still hadn't seen the whole thing, it seemed heretical to her. She couldn't let it stand. So we watched it together over the internet one Sunday afternoon. And I prepared to have a childhood memory either slightly enhanced or completely ruined. Before we started, she had me predict what was going to be in the second half.
但是当我的同事莉娜——她是本周节目的制作人，也是个音乐剧迷（我绝对不是）——发现我还没看完整个电影时，她觉得这简直不可理喻。她不能让这种事存在。所以一个周日下午我们通过互联网一起看了电影。我准备好让我的童年记忆要么稍作增强，要么彻底毁灭。开始之前，她让我预测一下后半部分会演什么。
I want, based on-- and this is based on my childhood memory and just what I would like to see, is the second half is just focused on my favorite two characters, Liesl and the hot mailman. I want to see their courtship. And then they get married. And that's the end of the movie.
基于……这是基于我的童年记忆，也是我希望看到的，后半部分只是围绕我最喜欢的两个角色，丽莎和帅气的邮差。我想看他们的恋爱过程。然后他们结婚。这就是电影的结局。
We hit play and started at the very beginning, started with the part I know. And the first half was more or less the simple, sunny movie I remembered. Seeing the kindly and dour nuns come on screen early on was like recognizing teachers I had in elementary school.
我们点击播放，从开头开始，从我熟悉的部分开始。前半部分或多或少是我记忆中简单、阳光的电影。看到善良而严厉的修女们在早期出现在银幕上，就像认出了我在小学时的老师一样。
Reverend Mother.
院长修女。
Sister Bernice.
伯尼斯修女。
I simply cannot find her.
我根本找不到她。
Maria?
玛丽亚？
There is that gazebo scene, when the mailman and Liesl sing to each other.
就是那个凉亭场景，邮差和丽莎互相唱歌。
(SINGING) I am 16, going on 17. I know that I'm naive.
（唱歌）我16岁了，快17岁了。我知道我很天真。
Then whirl around the gazebo, dancing.
然后围绕着凉亭转圈，跳舞。
Oh, my God. This still looks like so much fun.
哦，天哪。这看起来依然那么有趣。
Watching now, though, I saw a lot of things that I had completely missed as a kid, because, as a child, I'd apparently ignored anything that adults who are not Maria said to each other. Literally, none of that dialogue registered. It was like the mumbly grown-ups in Charlie Brown. My kid self had edited full characters out of the film. I barely remembered the baroness who wants to marry the dad.
现在看来，我看到了很多小时候完全错过的事情，因为作为孩子，我显然忽略了除了玛丽亚之外成年人之间说的任何话。说真的，那些对话完全没进入我的大脑。就像《花生漫画》里那些嘟囔的成年人。儿时的我把整个人物都从电影里删掉了。我几乎不记得那个想嫁给父亲的女男爵。
This really is exciting for me, Georg, being here with you.
乔治，能和你在一起，这真的让我很兴奋。
Oh, trees, lakes, mountains. When you've seen one, you've seen them all!
哦，树、湖、山。看了一处，就等于都看过了！
That is not what I mean, and you know it.
我不是那个意思，你知道的。
So any of their plot lines that were not resolved in the first half, moot. I also missed, of course, how Maria and the dad supposedly fall in love. The dad, by the way, was even meaner than I remembered, just cruel to Maria.
所以任何没有在前半部分解决的情节线，都不重要了。当然，我也错过了玛丽亚和父亲是如何坠入爱河的。顺便说一句，父亲比我记忆中更刻薄，对玛丽亚非常残忍。
Turn around, please.
请转过身。
What?
什么？
Turn. Hat off. It's the dress. You'll have to put on another one before you meet the children.
转身。摘掉帽子。这身衣服。你在见孩子们之前得换上一件别的。
But I don't have another one.
但我没有别的衣服。
And because of that, I still had a lot of trouble squaring the idea that anything between the two of them was remotely romantic.
正因如此，我仍然很难理解他们之间有什么浪漫可言。
He thinks he's in love with you.
他以为他爱上了你。
But that's not true.
但那不是真的。
Oh, they really spell it out.
哦，他们真的说得很清楚。
Yeah, buddy. You missed kind of a lot.
是啊，伙计。你错过了好多东西。
Surely, you've noticed the way he looks into your eyes. And you blushed in his arms when you were dancing just now.
难道你没注意到他看你的眼神吗？还有你刚才跳舞时在他怀里脸红了。
The one romance that still sparkled was between Liesl and the mailman. Though, watching again, I have to say the mailman was not as cute as I remembered.
唯一仍然闪耀的爱情是丽莎和邮差之间的。不过，再看一遍，我得说邮差没我记忆中那么可爱。
It's the mailman! Oh, he kind of looks like a Nazi.
是邮差！哦，他长得有点像纳粹。
Ralph, the mailman, comes back later in the first half to throw rocks on Liesl's window. That moment, I remember. Again, so dreamy. But the one that followed was completely over my head as a kid.
拉尔夫，那个邮差，后来在前半部分又回来往丽莎的窗户扔石头。那一刻我记得。同样，太梦幻了。但随后的那一幕在小时候的我看来完全没懂。
I didn't see. I mean, I didn't know you were-- Heil Hitler!
我没看见。我是说，我不知道你在……希特勒万岁！
Oh. "Heil Hitler"?
哦。“希特勒万岁”？
Yeah, "Heil Hitler." The hero of my version of The Sound of Music, who I'd hoped the second half would center around, he was the Nazi. Also, not the mailman. Yes, he was wearing a uniform and delivering messages, but he was not employed by the postal service, as my child self had understood. He was some kind of military messenger.
是的，“希特勒万岁”。我心中的《音乐之声》版本的英雄，我希望后半部分能围绕他展开，他竟然是纳粹。而且不是邮差。是的，他穿着制服在送信，但他并不是像儿时的我理解的那样受雇于邮局。他是一个军事信使。
The first half is peppered with a few more hints like this that things are going to take a turn historically in the second half of the movie. Uneasy talk about Austrian flags and something called an Anschluss, but all against the backdrop of a glamorous party. They're kind of easy to miss, if you're seven.
前半部分还点缀着一些类似这样的暗示，预示着历史将在电影后半部分发生转折。关于奥地利国旗和某种叫“德奥合并”的事情不安的谈话，但都是在奢华派对的背景下。如果你才七岁，这些很容易错过。
The last thing I missed as a kid? The big title card that says intermission in yellow script that comes on screen after Maria closes the door. Maybe it was on the second VHS. Lina and I fast forward through the music at intermission. And the second half starts.
小时候我错过的最后一件事？在玛丽亚关上门后出现在银幕上的黄色大字“中场休息”。也许那是在第二盘录像带上。莉娜和我快进跳过了中场休息的音乐。后半部分开始了。
Oh, my god, Lina. I can't believe there's more.
哦，我的上帝，莉娜。我不敢相信还有更多。
This is like a second movie for you.
这对你来说就像第二部电影。
Two, three--
二、三……
Oh, this is really weird. You haven't seen any of this.
哦，这真的很奇怪。你还没看过任何这些。
--fixe, six, seven.
五、六、七。
Except as the second half starts, I suddenly feel like I have seen all of this. Watching the children play ball in their backyard felt strangely familiar.
除了后半部分开始时，我突然觉得我好像看过这一切。看着孩子们在后院玩球感觉异常熟悉。
Six! Oh.
六！哦。
I'd spent so much time already with the von Trapps at their home that this new scene just felt like part of my memories. This confusing deja vu sticks with me, all the way through the scenes of Maria back at the abbey. It's not until the dad goes to meet Maria at the gazebo and declare his love for her that I am certain I have never seen this before.
我已经花了太多时间在冯·特拉普家，所以这个新场景感觉就像我记忆的一部分。这种令人困惑的既视感一直伴随着我，直到玛丽亚回到修道院。直到父亲去凉亭见玛丽亚并向她表白时，我才确定我绝对没看过这些。
Do you know when I first started loving you? That night at the dinner table when you sat on that ridiculous pine cone.
你知道我什么时候开始爱上你的吗？那天晚餐时你坐在那个可笑的松果上。
What? I knew the first time you blew that silly whistle.
什么？我知道第一次你吹那个愚蠢的哨子时。
Oh, my god.
哦，我的上帝。
Oh, my love.
哦，我的爱人。
This is so gross.
这太恶心了。
They basically just stared at each other three times, and now Maria was letting this horrible man marry her? I could not believe it. Just as I'm settling into the newness of the second half, gawking at Maria's wedding dress, everything in the movie shifts. The Nazis roll into town.
他们基本就互相瞪了三次，玛丽亚现在就要嫁给这个可怕的男人了？我无法相信。就在我适应后半部分的新鲜感、盯着玛丽亚的婚纱看时，电影里的一切都变了。纳粹开进了镇子。
It's incredibly abrupt, a cut from literal wedding bells to a bell tolling over a giant swastika flag on the town square. Lines of soldiers march across the plaza ominously. The colors seemed to drain out of the movie. The children show up next in drab brown clothes against a stony backdrop, instead of their perky curtain outfits from the first half. The characters, meanwhile, are dealing with their own whiplash. Rolfe surprises Liesl as she's getting into a car.
非常突然，从教堂的钟声直接切到了镇广场上覆盖着巨大纳粹旗帜的钟声。成排的士兵在广场上阴森地行进。电影里的色彩似乎褪去了。孩子们接着出现在阴沉的棕色衣服里，背景是石头的，而不是他们前半部分那些活泼的窗帘服。与此同时，角色们也在经历他们自己的震撼。罗尔夫在丽莎上车时吓了她一跳。
Liesl! Liesl!
丽莎！丽莎！
Rolfe!
罗尔夫！
I'm basically as excited to see Rolfe as Liesl is right here, because maybe this is when we get to the version of the second half I'd been wanting to see-- Rolfe and Liesl's courtship.
我见到罗尔夫基本和这里的丽莎一样兴奋，因为也许这就是我一直想看的后半部分——罗尔夫和丽莎的恋爱过程。
Rolfe, I'm so glad to see you. It's been such--
罗尔夫，见到你真高兴。已经有……
Good afternoon. You will take this, please, and deliver it to your father as soon as he comes home.
下午好。请拿着这个，在你父亲回家后尽快交给他。
Ouch, Rolfe. He's standing in front of a Nazi flag. Liesl is clearly disoriented, but still hopeful as she holds the telegram and coyly asks--
哎哟，罗尔夫。他正站在纳粹旗帜前。丽莎显然很困惑，但仍然抱着希望，她拿着电报娇羞地问——
Don't you want to come over tonight and deliver it yourself?
你今晚不想过来自己交给他吗？
I am now occupied with more important matters. And your father better be, too, if he knows what's good for him.
我正忙着更重要的事情。你父亲最好也是，如果他知道什么对自己有好处的话。
But Rolfe--
但罗尔夫……
Aw, Liesl, you chose a bad one.
哦，丽莎，你挑了个坏家伙。
This was the only relationship in the movie that interested me at all as a child. And it's sobering to see the whole realistic arc of it. As for the rest of the second half, it's predictable. You know their first escape isn't going to work out. It's obvious they'll win the singing contest. Great songs from the first half are just recycled in a weird way. The one moment that moves me, though, doesn't have anything to do with the characters I was attached to from the first half. It happens, surprisingly, when the dad starts singing a love song to his country onstage.
这是电影里唯一让我儿时感兴趣的关系。看到它现实的结局真的很沉重。至于后半部分的其他内容，是可以预见的。你知道他们的第一次逃跑不会成功。很明显他们会赢得歌唱比赛。前半部分的伟大歌曲只是以一种奇怪的方式被回收利用。不过，唯一让我感动的时刻与我前半部分依附的角色无关。令人惊讶的是，这发生在父亲开始在台上为他的国家唱起情歌时。
(SINGING) Edelweiss, Edelweiss, every morning you greet me.
（唱歌）雪绒花，雪绒花，每天清晨你迎接我。
He's doing it as an act of gentle defiance that makes the Nazi official's mustache twitch. And as the crowd joins in with him, I feel my throat catch a little. They remind me of people all around the world this summer in Hong Kong, Beirut, Belarus, here in America, who are longing to hold on to something as their own countries change rapidly, excruciatingly, around them.
他把它当作一种温和的蔑视行为，让纳粹官员的胡子抽动。当人群跟着他一起唱时，我感到喉咙有点哽咽。他们让我想起今年夏天世界各地的人们——香港、贝鲁特、白俄罗斯，就在美国这里，他们渴望守护属于自己的东西，而他们的国家却在迅速、痛苦地改变。
(SINGING) Edelweiss, Edelweiss, bless my hometown forever.
（唱歌）雪绒花，雪绒花，保佑我的家乡永远。
The darkest moment of the movie is perhaps at the very end, when the family has almost escaped, but then Rolfe finds them in the abbey. He raises a whistle to turn them in. But the dad stops and reasons with him.
电影最黑暗的时刻也许是在最后，当一家人几乎逃脱时，罗尔夫在修道院发现了他们。他举起哨子要告发他们。但父亲停下来，理智地劝说他。
You don't really belong to them.
你并不真正属于他们。
Stay where you are.
呆在那儿别动。
Come away with us-- before it's too late.
跟我们一起走吧——趁还来得及。
Rolfe looks scared and boyish. He relinquishes his gun and leans over, relieved. But then the dad takes it one step too far.
罗尔夫看起来既害怕又孩子气。他放下了枪，松了口气。但父亲却做得太过火了。
You'll never be one of them.
你永远不会成为他们的一员。
Lieutenant! Lieutenant, they're here! They're here, lieutenant!
中尉！中尉，他们在这儿！他们在这儿，中尉！
Rolfe chooses to betray them. It's such a sinister and dissonant scene, held up against the cotton candy first half. The family still makes it out in time, but in spite of him, not with his help. And that's the actual end of the movie, as far as I know today.
罗尔夫选择了背叛他们。这是一幕如此阴险而不和谐的场景，与前半部分的棉花糖情节形成对比。一家人及时逃脱了，但这尽管有他，并不是因为他的帮助。这就是我今天所知的电影的真正结局。
So here's my conclusion, having seen it all. You don't need the second half. It's actually better without it. The second half just takes one of my kid self's favorite characters, Rolfe, and makes him a villain, then takes the worst character, the dad, and makes him a hero. There are barely any new songs. Maria disappears as a person. Liesl just looks uncomfortable the whole time, trying to act like a child for another hour. Everything memorable and iconic about the movie-- "My Favorite Things," the kids singing good night, "Doe, a deer"-- that all happens in the first half.
所以我总结一下，看完了整部电影。你不需要后半部分。没有它反而更好。后半部分只是把儿时我最喜欢的角色罗尔夫变成了一个恶棍，然后把最糟糕的角色——父亲，变成了英雄。几乎没有新歌。玛丽亚作为一个人消失了。丽莎自始至终看起来都很不舒服，为了再演一小时而试图表现得像个孩子。电影里所有令人难忘和标志性的东西——“我最喜欢的东西”、孩子们唱晚安曲、“Doe, a deer”——都发生在前半部分。
But then I was at the beach this weekend with a friend, staring at the clouds and the kids throwing sand. And he said a thing that changed my feeling about the second half. He told me that, lately, he can last about three minutes feeling like everything is normal before he remembers it isn't. It made me understand the urge to include the dark end of the story in the movie about the singing family. Because once everything in the world has changed, you can't really will it to stay outside the frame.
但这个周末我和朋友在沙滩上，盯着云朵和玩沙子的孩子们。他说了一句话，改变了我对后半部分的看法。他告诉我，最近，他大概只能坚持三分钟感觉一切正常，然后就会想起事实并非如此。这让我理解了在关于唱歌家庭的电影中加入黑暗结局的渴望。因为一旦世界上的一切都变了，你就无法强迫它们留在画面之外。
Diane Wu is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, your ex-wife has a few thoughts about your marriage, and she makes a movie about that. That does not sound like that's going to be a good experience for you. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
戴安·吴是本节目的制作人之一。接下来，你的前妻对你们的婚姻有一些想法，并拍了一部关于此的电影。听起来那对你来说不会是个好的体验。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, at this point in the pandemic, where so many of us are still not going out to movie theaters, we thought, here at our program, let's do a movie night, a show about movies, stories about people who see something that most of us do not see in some film. Today's show is a rerun. We've arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, "Putting the Ease in Disease."
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在今天的节目中，疫情期间我们很多人仍然不去电影院，我们想，在我们的节目里，不如举办一场电影之夜，一期关于电影的节目，讲述那些在某部电影中看到了大多数人看不到的东西的人。今天的节目是重播。我们进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“让疾病变得舒适”。
So back when the pandemic first took hold, a lot of people were watching or rewatching the movie Contagion, which originally came out in 2011. Maybe you've seen this. It's about a deadly and fast-spreading virus that is spread by respiratory droplets. It goes around the world. Governments fail to contain it. And I think when we watch films like that or read books about the 1918 flu-- because it just, I don't know, scratches this itch, where we want some way to think about what we are going through right now. And it's just nice to see somebody else go through some version of it.
回到疫情刚开始时，很多人都在看或重温2011年上映的电影《传染病》。也许你见过。它讲的是一种致命且传播迅速的病毒，通过呼吸道飞沫传播。它传遍世界。政府无法控制。我觉得当我们看这样的电影或者读关于1918年流感书籍时——因为，我不知道，它挠到了痒处，我们想要某种方式来思考我们现在正在经历的事情。看到别人经历某种版本的事情总是好的。
One of our producers, Sean Cole, has never seen Contagion, but he found himself turning to this other movie, a movie about a virus that you've probably never heard of. It is a very different spin on the subject. Here's Sean.
我们的一位制作人肖恩·科尔从未看过《传染病》，但他发现自己转而看另一部电影，一部关于病毒的电影，你可能从未听说过。这是对该主题的一种非常不同的解读。这是肖恩。
You won't find this movie on Netflix or YouTube or anywhere like that-- or at least, I couldn't find it that way. I finally had to order a DVD from an online vintage movie store. It's clear my copy was pirated off cable-- skips a lot. And like all of the Contagion geeks, I was floored by some of the parallels to now, especially given that this movie came out in 1968, more than half a century ago. For instance, in this movie, instead of a bat, the vector of the virus is a bird, a toucan, that's stowed away aboard a Greek freighter somewhere near Central America. Then the boat docks in New York Harbor for inspection, and the first mate alerts the military that a lot of the crew is sick.
你不会在Netflix或YouTube或其他类似的地方找到这部电影——至少，我没法那样找到它。我最终不得不从一家在线老式电影店订购了一张DVD。很明显我买的是翻录自电缆的盗版——跳帧很严重。像所有《传染病》极客一样，我被它与当下的相似之处所震撼，特别是考虑到这部电影在1968年上映，超过半个世纪前。例如，在这部电影里，病毒传播媒介不是蝙蝠，而是一只大嘴鸟，它在某个地方靠近中美洲的一艘希腊货轮上搭便车。然后船停靠在纽约港接受检查，大副警告军方说船上很多人病了。
We'll have to hold the ship in quarantine indefinitely. If it is a virus, my guess, it's a brand new one, some kind of a mutation. No telling how long it'll take to identify it.
我们将不得不无限期地隔离这艘船。如果这是一种病毒，我猜它是全新的，某种变异。无法说明需要多长时间才能识别它。
The toucan is still on board, held in a makeshift chicken wire fence. But then it gets loose, flies straight into the city and starts infecting people. Just a few at first. The mayor of New York, an empty suit motivated mostly by money and poll numbers, holds a press conference, speaking into a microphone labeled WNYC, the public radio station in New York where I used to work. It was weird.
大嘴鸟还在船上，被关在简易的鸡丝围栏里。但随后它挣脱了，直接飞进城市，开始感染人。起初只有几个。纽约市长，一个主要受金钱和民调数字驱动的草包，召开了新闻发布会，对着标有WNYC的麦克风讲话，那是纽约的公共电台，我曾经工作的地方。这很怪。
There's absolutely no cause for alarm. Only 47 cases have been reported so far. However, the commissioner of health recommends that you wear a surgical mask when you are out in public. Now--
绝对没有理由惊慌。到目前为止只报告了47例。然而，卫生局局长建议你在公共场合佩戴医用口罩。现在——
He holds up a mask exactly like the one I wear every day. After the reporters leave, though, there's deep concern and dread. The health commissioner, an older Anthony Fauci type, scolds the mayor for underplaying the threat everyone's facing.
他举起了一个和我每天戴的完全一样的口罩。然而，记者们离开后，大家深感担忧和恐惧。卫生局局长，一位老派的福奇式人物，责骂市长轻视了所有人面临的威胁。
True, we've got a line on the 47 who reported to doctors, but--
没错，我们追踪到了向医生报告的那47人，但是——
But when you feel good, you don't go to a doctor.
但当你感觉良好时，你不会去看医生。
Lord knows how many more have it.
天知道还有多少人感染了。
But the virus only has a life of 10 days or so. You said so yourself.
但病毒的寿命只有10天左右。你自己说的。
Yes, but somebody who gets it on the 10th day and has it for another 10 days, and a week after he gets it, he gives it to somebody else and so on. Theoretically, it could go on for years.
是的，但如果有人在第10天感染，又带了10天，而且在他感染一周后，他又传染给了别人，如此类推。理论上，它可以持续数年。
Soon, everyone is scurrying around the city in a masked panic. Businesses suffer. A presidential envoy fast tracks the development of a vaccine. If it weren't for the 20-foot long cop cars and A-line mod dresses, it feels like some of these scenes could have been shot in Manhattan last weekend.
很快，每个人都在城市里戴着口罩惊慌失措地奔波。企业遭受重创。总统特使加速了疫苗的开发。如果不是因为20英尺长的警车和A字型摩登裙装，你会觉得这些场景中的一些可能是上周末在曼哈顿拍摄的。
Except, there's one major difference between this film and the Steven Soderberghian Contagion-like reality we're all living in. Because in this movie, the virus is not fatal. It doesn't even cause a fever or a cough. Instead, the main and only symptom is absolute euphoria. That's it. Everyone it infects experiences unbridled happiness and elation. Its victims begin acting kindly to one another, deferential. In just a couple of days, the city is transformed from this--
除了这部电影和我们所有人生活的史蒂文·索德伯格风格的《传染病》现实之间有一个主要区别。因为在这部电影里，病毒并不致命。它甚至不会导致发烧或咳嗽。相反，主要且唯一的症状是绝对的欣快感。就是这样。每个感染它的人都经历了肆无忌惮的幸福和狂喜。受害者开始对彼此表现得亲切、恭敬。仅仅几天，城市就从这样——
Come on, you jerk! The light ain't going to get any greener!
快点，你个混蛋！灯又不会变绿！
Why, you lazy, no good, rotten, stinking--
什么，你个懒惰的、没用的、烂透了的、臭烘烘的——
You're telling me when I came in?
你是在教我什么时候进来吗？
You're damn right I am!
你他妈说得对！
Who you shoving, mac? You own the sidewalk?
你推谁呢，伙计？这人行道是你家的？
--to this.
——变成了这样。
Good morning.
早上好。
Nice day, isn't it?
今天天气真不错，不是吗？
I'm sorry.
对不起。
Pardon me.
原谅我。
May I help you?
能帮到你吗？
The movie is called What's So Bad About Feeling Good? It's a comedy-- a romcom, really. And it is not a good movie, which is why you likely haven't heard of it, even though the lead actors are George Peppard from Breakfast at Tiffany's and The A-Team and Mary Tyler Moore from Mary Tyler Moore.
电影名叫《感觉良好有什么不好？》。这是一部喜剧——其实是浪漫喜剧。它不是一部好电影，这就是为什么你可能没听说过它，尽管主演是《蒂凡尼的早餐》和《天龙特攻队》的乔治·佩帕德，以及《玛丽·泰勒·摩尔秀》的玛丽·泰勒·摩尔。
And they do a good job. Pretty much everyone in the cast is really skilled. But the whole production is outlandishly campy and caricaturistic. There are a few very awkward choices. Cartoon word balloons emerge from the toucan's mouth sometimes when it squawks, so you know what it's thinking. Oh, and there's a schmaltzy AM radio theme song, kind of a knockoff of Burt Bacharach.
他们演得很好。演员阵容里的每个人都非常熟练。但整个制作显得极其夸张和脸谱化。有一些非常尴尬的选择。大嘴鸟尖叫时，有时会出现卡通对话气泡，让你知道它在想什么。哦，还有一个老掉牙的调频广播主题曲，有点像伯特·巴卡拉克的山寨版。
(SINGING) What's so wrong with that happy sensation, that sense of utter elation? What's so bad about feeling good?
（唱歌）那种快乐的感觉有什么不好？那种完全的欣快感？感觉良好有什么不好？
That said, it's also a great movie in the way that silly B movies can be so satisfying, especially the arcane ones that make you feel like a kid watching adults mess up for the first time. I have a greatest hits list of them in my head. Wild in the Streets, about ageist hippies waging a coup against the US government. Invasion of the Bee Girls, about a race of murderous women, who are also bees. Both of which you can watch online for free.
话虽如此，它在愚蠢的B级片能让人满意的方式上也是一部伟大的电影，特别是那些稀奇古怪、让你觉得自己像个看着大人们第一次搞砸了的孩子一样的电影。我脑子里有一个它们的金曲列表。《野蛮青春》，关于反年龄歧视的嬉皮士对美国政府发动政变。《蜜蜂女郎》，关于一群杀人女性，她们同时也是蜜蜂。这两部你都可以在网上免费观看。
But since it's so hard to find a copy of this movie, let me just continue taking you through the plot in a kind of abbreviated, radio-ified Cliff's Notes version for your movie not-going enjoyment. So George Peppard and Mary Tyler Moore are Pete and Liz, two characters who are tailor-made for this particular plot, because they don't contain an ounce of euphoria. They're brooding existentialist archetypes that have dropped out of society, living in the East Village. They'd be boyfriend and girlfriend if they believed in that sort of thing. For no discernible reason, or maybe because the script wasn't working and they had to fix it quickly, there's a lot of voiceover by these two.
但由于很难找到这部电影的副本，让我继续以一种简短的、广播版的“悬念摘要”形式带你走过剧情，供你“不看电影”的享受。所以乔治·佩帕德和玛丽·泰勒·摩尔饰演的皮特和莉兹是为这个特定剧情量身定制的角色，因为他们身上没有一丝欣快感。他们是那种退出了社会的沉思型存在主义者，住在东村。如果他们相信那种事，他们会是男女朋友。由于没有明显的原因，或者是因为剧本行不通，他们需要快速修改，这两个人有很多旁白。
A couple of years ago, I was just like the rest of you conformists. I was in advertising, name on the door, carpet on the floor, an ulcer, headaches, the whole bit. But I wised up to that phony world and came down here. So did Liz. She was on the treadmill, too.
几年前，我和你们这些循规蹈矩的人一样。我在做广告，名牌挂在门上，地板铺着地毯，还有溃疡、头痛，全套的。但我看透了那个虚伪的世界，搬到了这里。莉兹也是。她也在那台跑步机上。
I sure was. Uptown supper clubs, singing schmaltzy songs to the drunks, fighting to get to the top of the ladder. And then my heart got into the act, and somebody stepped on it. Pills to sleep, pills to stay awake. Finally, I asked myself, for what? This was the answer.
我当然是。城里的晚宴俱乐部，给醉鬼唱那些老掉牙的歌，拼命爬到梯子顶端。然后我的心也参与了进来，有人踩了它一脚。吃药睡觉，吃药保持清醒。最后，我问自己，为了什么？这就是答案。
This being the communal building they live in with a tribe of other unhappy nihilists collecting unemployment. They all look a little like cave people at a gallery opening. One of them spends every hour of every day completely enveloped inside of a sack. They call her the Sack.
这就是他们住的集体公寓，还有一帮其他不快乐的虚无主义者领着失业救济金。他们看起来都有点像画廊开幕式上的穴居人。其中一个人每天每小时都完全包裹在麻袋里。他们叫她“麻袋”。
Since the problems of life are insoluble, one should draw into complete isolation and live a life of total non-involvement with other people.
既然生活的困境无法解决，就应该退回到彻底的孤立中，过一种与其他人完全不接触的生活。
The Sack is right.
“麻袋”是对的。
Meanwhile, a little ways downtown, the Faucian commissioner of health pretty quickly figures out how the virus works.
与此同时，市中心，那位福奇式的卫生局局长很快就弄清楚了病毒是如何工作的。
And it has to be transmitted by respiration. All that bird has to do is get within breathing distance of somebody, and pop goes the weasel.
它必须通过呼吸传播。那只鸟只需要进入某个人的呼吸距离内，啪的一声黄鼠狼就出来了。
Cue the toucan, who flies into Pete and Liz's window one morning while they're sleeping, loiters for a minute next to Pete's face, and leaves. Pete wakes up early and heads up to the roof. Liz climbs up after him, concerned.
大嘴鸟出场，一天早上在皮特和莉兹睡觉时飞进他们的窗户，在皮特的脸旁徘徊了一分钟，然后离开。皮特早早醒来，往屋顶走去。莉兹担心地爬上去追他。
Pete!
皮特！
Come here.
过来。
What happened?
发生了什么事？
Come here. Look. In this cruddy pile of junk, a flower.
过来。看。在这堆破烂垃圾里，有一朵花。
Pete, what's wrong? What's the matter with you?
皮特，怎么了？你出什么事了？
I don't know. Ever since I got up, I've been feeling strange, kind of-- I don't think I can explain it to you, but everything seems different. Hey, listen.
我不知道。自从我起床，我就感觉很奇怪，有点——我觉得我没法解释，但一切似乎都不同了。嘿，听。
To what? The traffic?
听什么？交通声？
Kids laughing.
孩子们的笑声。
You know why they're laughing? Because they're not old enough to read the newspaper. You take a look at the front page and then try laughing. The world's a stinking, hopeless mess! Oh, Pete, you're sick. You know, sometimes a high fever can make you feel this way.
你知道他们为什么笑吗？因为他们还没大到能读报纸。你看一眼头版，然后再试着笑笑。这世界是个臭烘烘、绝望的烂摊子！哦，皮特，你病了。你知道，有时高烧会让你有这种感觉。
I feel great.
我感觉棒极了。
That's what I mean!
那就是我的意思！
At this point, it's worth noting why someone might want to make a film about the need for euphoria in 1968. The front page Liz is talking about would include headlines like "Martin Luther King is Slain in Memphis," "Robert Kennedy Dead," "Police Battle Demonstrators in the Streets"-- also, "Viet Cong Storm US Embassy." We were a nation at war, both abroad and with itself, with protests and riots in cities across the country, and a presidential candidate running on a platform of law and order, and also courting segregationists.
此时值得注意的是，为什么有人想在1968年拍一部关于欣快感需求的电影。莉兹说的那个头版将包括这样的标题：“马丁·路德·金在孟菲斯遇害”、“罗伯特·肯尼迪之死”、“警察在街头与抗议者战斗”——还有，“越共袭击美国大使馆”。我们是一个处于战争中的国家，既是对外，也是对自己，全国各地的城市有抗议和暴乱，还有一位总统候选人在竞选纲领上以法律和秩序为诉求，同时也讨好种族隔离主义者。
And given all that, you might ask, what is so bad about feeling good? Which is what the mayor in the movie wanted to know. In one of the first crisis management meetings with his cabinet, they're running down the symptoms for him and tell him the virus stops people from brooding. But it's worse than that.
考虑到这一切，你可能会问，感觉良好有什么不好？这也是电影里的市长想知道的。在与内阁的第一次危机管理会议中，他们向他介绍了症状，并告诉他病毒阻止了人们沉思。但比这更糟。
Mr. Mayor, 82% not only stop brooding, they stop smoking. 93% stop drinking.
市长先生，82%的人不仅停止了沉思，他们还戒烟了。93%的人戒酒了。
What's wrong with that?
那有什么不好？
In terms of dollars and cents, it's disastrous. Our city is facing a drastic loss in income from sales tax.
从金钱的角度来看，这是灾难性的。我们的城市正面临销售税收入的剧烈损失。
That's ridiculous. 47 people? Drop in a bucket.
这太荒谬了。47个人？沧海一粟。
But if this goes unchecked for a month, by mathematical progression, half of New York will have the virus. You know what that means. It means a loss in cigarette and liquor taxes, more than $180 million.
但如果这种情况一个月不受控制，按照数学递进，一半的纽约人会感染病毒。你知道那意味着什么吗。这意味着香烟和酒税损失超过1.8亿美元。
$180 million? Brady, what are you sitting there for? Get that bird!
1.8亿美元？布雷迪，你还坐在那干嘛？抓住那只鸟！
Yes, sir.
是的，长官。
Brady is the chief of police. Capture the bird, they can extract its tissues, come up with a cure, and stave off an economic crisis. Because, of course, what's the most important thing a politician thinks of in a potential pandemic? How to save the economy. Meantime, Pete, much to Liz's horror, has shaved off his beard, cut his hair, and is talking about trying to get his old advertising job back. Which-- quick digression-- interests me because it's the opposite of subversive. Once these nonconformists get infected, instead of dropping out, they drop in.
布雷迪是警察局长。抓住了鸟，他们就可以提取组织，研发出治愈方法，并防止经济危机。因为当然，政治家在潜在的疫情中首先想到的是什么？如何拯救经济。与此同时，皮特，让莉兹惊恐的是，他剃掉了胡子，剪了头发，还在谈论试图找回他以前的广告工作。这——快速跑题——让我感兴趣，因为它与颠覆相反。一旦这些不循规蹈矩的人被感染，他们不再退出，而是加入。
Pete feels so good, in fact, that once he figures out what's, quote unquote, "wrong with him," he wants to share it with everyone, starting with Liz. In an age when all of us are actively avoiding each other's bodies like the plague, because of the plague, it's wild to watch someone actively trying to spread a virus like this.
皮特感觉太好了，事实上，一旦他弄清楚了自己到底哪里“不对劲”，他就想和每个人分享，从莉兹开始。在一个我们所有人都像躲避瘟疫一样积极避免他人身体接触的时代——因为瘟疫——看着有人积极试图传播这样的病毒真是太狂野了。
One little kiss, and you'll have it, too.
亲一下，你也会有的。
I don't want it.
我不想要。
Just one little kiss. You'll like yourself in the morning.
就亲一下。早上你会喜欢自己的。
I don't want it, Pete.
我不想要，皮特。
We'll get married, a real marriage--
我们会结婚，真正的婚姻——
I don't want it.
我不想要。
--a church wedding.
——教堂婚礼。
Chasing her around the room.
在房间里追着她跑。
We'll get a little place in Jersey. We'll have some kids, and I'll mow the lawn.
我们会在泽西岛买个小地方。我们会生几个孩子，我来修草坪。
And give up all this?
然后放弃这一切？
Eventually, in a completely unbelievable moment that would never have survived the MeToo movement, Pete disguises himself as a nihilist German philosopher and tries to pressure Liz into bed, finally settling for a kiss. He exposes the rest of the gang, too. They all shave, cut their hair, Queer Eye their apartments. The Sack climbs out of her sack. And the toucan, remarkably, keeps coming back. It becomes their pet. They call him Amigo. At the same time, the mayor is bundled off to an emergency bunker so that he doesn't get sick. A TV reporter buttonholes him on the way in.
最终，在一个完全不可思议、在“Me Too”运动中绝对活不下来的时刻，皮特乔装成虚无主义的德国哲学家，试图向莉兹施压上床，最后勉强亲了一口。他还揭露了其他团伙。他们都刮了胡子，剪了头发，公寓也变得精致。那个“麻袋”从麻袋里爬了出来。大嘴鸟，值得注意的是，一直回来。它成了他们的宠物。他们叫它“朋友”。与此同时，市长被匆忙送进紧急掩体，以免生病。一名电视记者在路上拦住他。
Tell me, sir, is there any truth to the rumor that there's been a spread in the epidemic?
告诉我，长官，传闻疫情蔓延是否有真相？
Epidemic? Well, I'd hardly call it an epidemic. After all, we only have 180 million-- 47 cases.
疫情？好吧，我很难称之为疫情。毕竟，我们只有1.8亿……47例。
Well, why then, sir, are you visiting the fallout shelter?
那么，长官，为什么你要造访防空洞？
Just a routine inspection, last Friday of every month.
只是例行检查，每个月的最后一个星期五。
But today is Saturday, sir.
但今天是星期六，长官。
Well, better late than never.
好吧，迟做总比不做强。
It took me watching this scene a few times, trying to figure out why it sounded so familiar. And then I was like, oh, yeah.
我看了几次这个场景，试图弄明白为什么听起来这么耳熟。然后我就想，哦，是啊。
At the height of the protest outside the White House, President Trump was moved for a time to the bunker, something that hasn't happened since 9/11.
在白宫外抗议达到高潮时，特朗普总统有一段时间被转移到了掩体里，这是9/11以来从未发生过的事情。
I was there for a tiny, little short period of time, and it was much more for an inspection. There was no--
我在那里呆了一小会儿，更多是为了检查。没有什么——
Anyway, there aren't only 47 cases for long. And that is largely due to the efforts of Pete and Liz and their friends. They wage a campaign to spread the virus intentionally, by subterfuge. Liz and the Sack volunteer to hand out masks to their fellow citizens, breathing on them first.
总之，不只有47例了。这在很大程度上归功于皮特、莉兹和他们的朋友们的努力。他们通过诡计蓄意传播病毒。莉兹和“麻袋”自愿向同胞发放口罩，先对着口罩呼吸。
While the Sack made sure that every mask was specially treated with the virus, I made sure that nobody got away without one.
当“麻袋”确保每个口罩都经过病毒特殊处理时，我确保没有任何人漏掉。
I was in charge of transportation, assisted by Conrad. Our specialty was the subway at rush hour. Where the biggest crowds were breathing in, we were there, breathing out.
我负责交通，康拉德协助。我们的专长是高峰时段的地铁。哪里有最多的人在大口呼吸，我们就在那里，大口呼出。
They breathe on peanuts and feed them to the pigeons. Liz and another friend get jobs as burlesque dancers. Their shtick is blowing soap bubbles into people's faces. And in just a couple of days, the number of cases explodes to about two million, about a quarter of the city's population. Cabbies stop in the middle of the street to let pedestrians cross in front of them. Marriage license applications flood City Hall, Pete and Liz's among them. Barbershop lines are staggering. People literally dance in the streets with joy. It's a disaster.
他们对着花生吹气，喂给鸽子吃。莉兹和另一个朋友找了脱衣舞女的工作。她们的噱头是朝人们脸上吹肥皂泡。仅仅几天，病例数量就爆炸到了大约200万，约占全市人口的四分之一。出租车司机停在街道中间，让行人从他们面前经过。结婚许可申请涌向市政厅，皮特和莉兹的也在其中。理发店排队的人数惊人。人们真的在街上快乐地跳舞。这是一场灾难。
Finally, the president's envoy is helicoptered into New York City to save the day and, frankly, to save the movie. It's Dom Deluise from Blazing Saddles, Space Balls, Robin Hood, Men in Tights.
最后，总统特使被直升机运送到纽约市，以拯救局面，坦率地说，是为了拯救电影。他是《闪亮的马鞍》、《太空炮弹》、《罗宾汉》中的多姆·德路易斯。
I have a statement from the president.
我有一份总统的声明。
Dom Deluise. I love Dom Deluise. He looms so large in my childhood comedy pantheon. He's atomically funny, even in this very not good film. His character, Jay Gardner Monroe, is way more confident and bossy and conceited than he is capable. He snaps his fingers at his aides, uses the word "repeat" before repeating himself, like a military general. Anyway, he heads straight to the bunker and tells the mayor and everyone that if the toucan isn't caught before the tally reaches 3 million cases, he's putting plan CC-27 into effect.
多姆·德路易斯。我爱多姆·德路易斯。他在我的童年喜剧万神殿中占有很大地位。他非常滑稽，即使在这部非常烂的电影里。他的角色，杰伊·加德纳·门罗，比他所能达到的更自信、专横和自负。他向助手打响指，在重复自己之前使用“重复”这个词，就像一个军事将军。总之，他径直前往掩体，告诉市长和所有人，如果不赶在统计数字达到300万例之前抓住那只大嘴鸟，他将执行“CC-27计划”。
The bridges, tunnels, airports will be closed. Repeat, closed! Not one single person will get in or out of New York.
桥梁、隧道、机场将关闭。重复，关闭！没有任何一个人能进出纽约。
But Mr. Monroe, do you realize we have 52 conventions coming in next week?
但门罗先生，你意识到下周我们有52场大会要举行吗？
Conventions? Do you realize what would happen if this got to Washington? Republicans agreeing with Democrats and vice versa? This bird could destroy our two-party system, the very foundation of our great democracy.
大会？你意识到如果这传到华盛顿会发生什么吗？共和党人同意民主党人，反之亦然？这只鸟可能会摧毁我们的两党制，我们伟大民主的根基。
The tally board is at 2.2 million cases at this point. And this is really the final and maybe most alarming parallel between our story and real life. As Monroe watches the numbers tick upward, he shakes his head in disgust.
统计板此时已达到220万例。这真的是我们的故事和现实生活中最后、也许最令人震惊的相似之处。当门罗看着数字上涨时，他厌恶地摇了摇头。
Those commies sure are sneaky. Oh, come on. You don't think for one moment that this thing is just an accident, do you? Do you? When that bird landed on that ship, its position was--
那些共产党人真狡猾。哦，快点。你不会真的以为这件事只是意外吧？你以为吗？当那只鸟降落在船上时，它的位置是——
Longitude 82, latitude 24.
经度82，纬度24。
24. Not very far from Cuba, eh? Take my word for it. That bird is a hook-nosed missile sent here by You Know Who.
24。离古巴不太远，呃？相信我。那只鸟是“你知道是谁”派来的钩鼻导弹。
You Know Who-- Fidel Castro.
“你知道是谁”——菲德尔·卡斯特罗。
Look at the facts. When people get the bug, they suddenly love the world. Now if You Know Who was getting ready to act up again, what would be better than to give Americans a sense of security, a false sense of security and euphoria?
看看事实。当人们感染病毒时，他们突然爱上了这个世界。现在，如果“你知道是谁”准备再次行动，有什么比给美国人一种安全感、一种虚假的安全感和欣快感更好的呢？
Mr. Monroe, you're not suggesting this virus was artificially produced in a laboratory?
门罗先生，你不是在暗示这种病毒是在实验室人工制造的吧？
Yes, virus produ-- laboratory, yes.
是的，病毒制造……实验室，是的。
Medical impossibility. Just couldn't have happened.
医学上的不可能。根本不可能发生。
That's what they said about the power failure here in New York in '65. And what about the Asian flu? That came straight, believe you me, from red China.
他们对65年纽约的停电也是这么说的。那亚洲流感呢？那可是直接，相信我，来自红色中国。
Of course, it's satire, and in that way, it's cathartic. But when I got to that scene, it suddenly felt like every other part of the movie had been an escape from what's going on. It's funny that one of the most ludicrous pieces of dialogue is also practically a quote we've heard in the news in 2020, and not as a joke.
当然，这是讽刺，从这个意义上讲，它是宣泄性的。但当我看到那一幕时，它突然觉得这部电影的其他部分就像是对正在发生的事情的逃避。有趣的是，其中最荒谬的一段对话竟然也是我们在2020年的新闻中听到过、而且并不是作为笑话的几乎一模一样的引用。
There's so much more of the story left, but just to abridge, so they finally manage to isolate the virus. Amazingly, because it's a movie, they develop a vaccine, like, that day. But they still have to test it out. So they spray it in Pete and Liz's nuptial bed in the hotel room where they're spending their wedding night and set up a hidden camera behind the air vent. Everybody in the bunker, the mayor, the Fauci character, Jay Gardner Monroe, all of them sit and monitor the couple on a big screen as morning arrives. Liz wakes up to Pete coming back from an errand. He's still wearing his suit, but he's disheveled, messy hair, smoking.
故事还有很多，但简而言之，他们终于设法分离出了病毒。令人惊讶的是，因为它是电影，他们在那一天开发出了疫苗。但他们仍然需要进行测试。所以他们把它喷在皮特和莉兹的婚床上，并在通风口后面设置了一个隐藏摄像头。地堡里的每个人，市长、福奇角色、杰伊·加德纳·门罗，所有人都坐着，在清晨监视着这一对。莉兹醒来，发现皮特刚从差事回来。他仍然穿着西装，但看起来很邋遢，头发乱蓬蓬的，抽着烟。
Good morning, darling. I didn't hear you.
早上好，亲爱的。我没听到你动静。
Couldn't sleep. Went out for coffee and cigarettes.
睡不着。出去喝咖啡、抽烟了。
Room service is probably up, and I'll order breakfast.
客房服务可能上来了，我要点早餐。
No, never mind. I don't want any.
不，别管了。我什么都不想要。
Oh, but Pete, you really should eat something.
哦，但皮特，你真的应该吃点东西。
Don't bug me!
别烦我！
Jay Gardner Monroe, watching on the monitor from the bunker, is psyched.
在监视器前观看的杰伊·加德纳·门罗很兴奋。
Well, he's back to normal. It worked, doc.
好吧，他恢复正常了。成功了，医生。
Not her, she doesn't seem to have changed a bit.
不是她，她看起来一点都没变。
And I don't know what this says about me, but of all the scenes in the movie, this is the one I remember the most clearly from the first time I saw it. I've actually kind of carried it around all of these years because it's genuinely so sad. Liz looks like her heart is breaking in real time.
我不知道这说明了我什么，但在电影的所有场景中，这是我第一次看时记得最清楚的一个。我其实这些年来一直把它带在身边，因为它真的太悲伤了。莉兹看起来心在实时破碎。
No, don't ask me to go back. Remember what we had. Remember it. Cling to it.
不，别要求我回到过去。记住我们拥有的。记住它。紧紧抓住它。
You're kidding yourself. You talk about goodness and kindness. Read the front page and try and find some.
你在自欺欺人。你谈论善良和仁慈。读读头版，试着找一点出来。
Pete, I can't go back. I couldn't live that kind of life ever again.
皮特，我回不去了。我再也过不了那种生活了。
Pete shrugs.
皮特耸耸肩。
OK. You drink your poison, and I'll drink mine.
好吧。你喝你的毒药，我喝我的。
There's no doubt about him. That was certainly a positive reaction.
毫无疑问。那肯定是一个积极的反应。
Positive. There's a happy ending. Liz decides to leave New York and move home, but at the very last minute, she goes to say goodbye to Amigo, the bird, who's in a zoo now. And Pete's there, too.
积极。有一个快乐的结局。莉兹决定离开纽约搬回家，但在最后一分钟，她去向“朋友”告别，那只鸟现在在动物园。皮特也在那。
Liz? Liz!
莉兹？莉兹！
They do that romcom running thing.
他们做了那种浪漫喜剧式的奔跑。
Pete!
皮特！
And just like that, they're back together. The city spews the vaccine into the air via factory chimneys and exhaust pipes, and most of New York lives miserably ever after. But some people stay pleasant and uplifted because, major plot twist, 50% of the people who seem to be infected actually never got the virus in the first place. The joy just rubbed off on them. And Liz was one of those people, which is why she didn't get, quote unquote, "better" in the hotel room, which is actually the moral of the movie, that happiness is a choice.
就这样，他们又在一起了。城市通过工厂烟囱和排气管将疫苗喷入空中，大多数纽约人从此生活在痛苦中。但有些人依然保持愉快和振奋，因为，重大情节转折，那些看起来被感染的人中50%其实根本没有感染病毒。喜悦只是传染给了他们。而莉兹就是其中之一，这就是为什么她在酒店房间里没有“好转”，这其实是电影的寓意，幸福是一种选择。
But watching the movie during this pandemic, I drew another darker conclusion. Somehow, that wiggly weird jolt of recognition I got over and over again, what it felt like was, this is how it goes. When faced with a crisis like this, governments will minimize the severity of the danger. They'll value the wrong things. They'll focus on the economy over people's lives and blame foreigners in an ugly, xenophobic way. I'm sure there's a version of America where all that might not happen, but we're not living in that America right now. And Pete and Liz weren't living in it either. If it's possible for human beings to do the wrong thing, we'll figure out a way. We're resourceful like that.
但在疫情期间看这部电影，我得出了另一个更黑暗的结论。不知何故，我反复感受到的那种古怪的认同感，感觉就像是：事情就是这样。当面临这样的危机时，政府会轻视危险的严重性。他们会重视错误的事情。他们会优先考虑经济而不是人的生命，并以一种丑陋、排外的方式责备外国人。我相信有一个版本的美国可能不会发生这一切，但我们现在没生活在那样的美国里。皮特和莉兹也没生活在里面。如果人类有可能做错事，我们总能想出办法。我们就是那样足智多谋。
Sean Cole is one of the producers of our show.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Three, "Director's Cut." So our show today is about people who have a very particular take on some film. And the person in this next story finds himself in a situation that not many of us are ever going to be in. His ex-wife decided to revisit the part of their lives as their marriage fell apart and make a movie about it, or anyway, about a couple whose life seems very, very parallel to theirs in lots of ways. This fictional couple gets married real young. They're trying to make it in LA. The woman gets a big break. She leaves the husband at that point. This all happened in real life, too. The guy's name is Will Weldon. Elna Baker explains what happened next.
第三幕，“导演剪辑版”。所以我们今天的节目是关于对某部电影有非常独特看法的人。而下一个故事中的人发现自己处于我们大多数人永远不会面临的情况。他的前妻决定重新审视他们婚姻破裂时期的生活，并拍了一部关于它的电影，或者说，关于一对生活在许多方面似乎与他们非常平行的夫妇。这对虚构的夫妇很早就结婚了。他们试图在洛杉矶闯荡。女人取得了重大突破。她在那个时刻离开了丈夫。这一切在现实生活中也发生了。那个男人的名字叫威尔·威尔登。埃尔娜·贝克解释了后来发生了什么。
Will heard about the movie from some friends when his ex-wife started working on it. The very thought of it made him anxious. His ex, Rebecca, eventually brought it up with him. She said the film was only loosely based on their marriage, which definitely did not help. He tried to put it out of his head. A year and a half later, he was scrolling around online.
威尔从一些朋友那里听说了这部电影，当时他的前妻开始制作它。一想到它他就感到焦虑。他的前妻瑞贝卡最终和他提起了这件事。她说这部电影只是松散地基于他们的婚姻，这绝对没帮上忙。他试图把它赶出脑海。一年半后，他在网上滚动浏览。
And I saw on Facebook people posting the trailer for the movie and being like, hey, go see this movie if it's in a theater near you, because it was made by Rebecca Adelman, and she's great and so funny. And I saw those popping up, and then I just had this moment where I was like, oh, the moment is here. And that was when I was filled with the most dread.
我在Facebook上看到人们发布电影预告片，说：嘿，去看这部电影，如果它在你附近的电影院放映的话，因为它是由瑞贝卡·阿德尔曼制作的，她太棒了，太有趣了。我看到这些弹出来，然后我有了那种感觉：哦，时刻到了。那就是我最充满恐惧的时候。
What were those thoughts?
那些想法是什么？
For me, the thing I was the most afraid of is that the movie would portray me accurately.
对我来说，我最害怕的是这部电影会准确地刻画我。
Will's candid about his flaws. Admits he was kind of a dud as a husband. Will and Rebecca met when she was 23. He was just 19. They were together for eight years, married for almost five. During that time, he was mostly unemployed, though he eventually started doing part-time work, walking dogs and house sitting. He did some stand-up, but not very often. Mostly, he'd spend his time--
威尔对自己的缺点很坦率。承认他作为丈夫有点失败。威尔和瑞贝卡相遇时她才23岁。他只有19岁。他们在一起八年，结婚近五年。在此期间，他大部分时间处于失业状态，尽管他最终开始做一些兼职工作，遛狗和照看房子。他做过一些单口相声，但频率不高。大多数时候，他会花时间——
Refreshing Gawker, or I was playing Playstation, or I was literally just sitting there, thinking about how I should be doing something. I had no actual goals, and I wasn't striving for anything. That was, I think, the defining quality that ended our marriage.
刷新Gawker，或者我在玩PlayStation，或者我真的只是坐在那儿，想着我应该做点什么。我没有任何实际目标，我也没为任何事努力。我认为，这就是导致我们婚姻终结的决定性特质。
Because she was the ambitious one and disciplined. She wanted to be a TV writer. She'd wake up early to work on scripts. And when he watched the trailer, that was in it.
因为她是那个有野心且有纪律的人。她想成为电视编剧。她会早起写剧本。当他看预告片时，那就在里面。
And she is the harder worker and actually wants things.
而且她是那个更努力工作、真正想要东西的人。
I got the job.
我得到这份工作了。
What?
什么？
They just hired me as a writer.
他们刚雇我做编剧。
Woo! My wife is the smartest woman in the world! Look how awesome she is! We're going to be rich. Can I get a Nintendo?
呜！我的妻子是世界上最聪明的女人！看她多棒！我们要发财了。我能买个任天堂吗？
Seeing the trailer made it so much worse. Now he realized the film would probably return him to some very painful times he'd rather not relive, like the way their marriage ended.
看到预告片让情况变得更糟。现在他意识到电影可能会让他回到一些他宁愿不重温的痛苦时期，比如他们婚姻结束的方式。
To me at the time, it really felt like it came out of nowhere. She got home from work, and she just had a very strange-- you know the way people will start a-- they'll be like, so. And then she sat me down and she was just telling me about how she was unhappy in the relationship, and she had been for a long time.
当时对我来说，它真的感觉像凭空出现。她下班回家，她有一种非常奇怪的——你知道人们开始一种——他们会说，那么。然后她让我坐下，她只是告诉我她在关系中有多不快乐，而且她已经这样很久了。
And then me being like, gee, I don't know why this hasn't-- why none of this has come up before. I just loved her, and I really felt like we should try and give it another chance. And she was like, mm, I don't know. And at a certain point, we were talking. And I was like, who are we fooling here? It really seems like you're done, and this is done. And she was like, OK.
然后我就像是，天哪，我不知道为什么这个——为什么这些都没提过。我只是爱她，我真的觉得我们应该尝试再给一次机会。她说，嗯，我不知道。在某个时候，我们交谈时。我说，我们这是在欺骗谁呢？看来你真的结束了，这一切都结束了。她说，OK。
Will moved out after just a week, started crashing on friends' couches. He was devastated, didn't understand what went wrong. And there were other scenes from their lives that he'd hate to see in a movie.
威尔只住了一周就搬走了，开始在朋友沙发上凑合。他崩溃了，不明白哪里出了问题。还有其他他们生活中的场景是他不想在电影里看到的。
I'm sure there will be conversations with her mom or her sister and her friends. I don't know if they were like, come on, girl. You gotta dump him. Those will probably be the toughest parts, because I imagine those will be things that will be very based in reality.
我肯定会有她妈妈或妹妹和朋友们的谈话。我不知道她们是不是那种，拜托，姑娘。你必须甩了他。那可能是最艰难的部分，因为我想象那些会是非常基于现实的东西。
The film, which is called Paper Year, came out in early 2018. It's got 71% on Rotten Tomatoes. Critics comment on how authentic the couple's love coming undone feels. For a while, Will couldn't bring himself to see it. But a month ago, he suggested we watch it together. And I was into the idea.
这部电影名叫《纸年》，于2018年初上映。它在烂番茄上有71%的好评。评论家评论说这对夫妇的爱情瓦解感觉多么真实。有一段时间，威尔无法强迫自己看它。但一个月前，他建议我们一起看。我很喜欢这个想法。
I'm going through a divorce right now. It's a very strange time of life. I go on a lot of long walks. I stopped watching television for a year so I wouldn't avoid my feelings. All I read are self-help books. And when I go to parties, I corner divorced people and badger them for details about what this was like for them and how they got through it. Divorce is like my own personal disaster porn. So watching a movie about a divorce with the person who it happened to, it's all I want to do. And Will thought it would make it easier for him to see it for the first time.
我正在经历离婚。这是生命中非常奇怪的时期。我走很多长路。我停看电视一年，这样我就不会逃避自己的感受。我只读自助书籍。当我去参加派对时，我会把离婚的人拉到角落，追问他们对此的细节，以及他们是如何挺过来的。离婚就像我自己的个人灾难色情。所以和一个经历过它的人一起看关于离婚的电影，这就是我唯一想做的。而威尔认为这会让他更容易第一次看它。
This is a better way, to view it with other people, than just, it's 3:00 in the morning. I'm alone. The lights are off. I've gotten up in secret, and I'm watching it in the middle of the night so I can just deny having ever seen it if I want to.
这是一个更好的方式，和别人一起观看，而不是在凌晨3点。我独自一人。灯关着。我偷偷起床，在半夜观看，这样如果我想的话，我可以否认看过它。
OK.
OK。
[DOG BARKING]
[狗叫]
Hi, puppy.
嗨，小狗。
Hi. This is Jack.
嗨。这是杰克。
I met Will where he was staying. He's dog sitting at a sleek Los Angeles home overlooking a canyon-- furry throw pillows, an open layout, pomegranate and lemon trees framing your view of the valley, all really expensive. Will is on high alert. Any time I move anything, he is careful to put it back exactly where it had been.
我在威尔住的地方见到了他。他在洛杉矶一处俯瞰峡谷的时尚住宅里照看狗——毛绒绒的靠垫，开放式布局，石榴树和柠檬树框住了你对山谷的视野，一切都很贵。威尔处于高度戒备状态。我移动任何东西，他都小心翼翼地把它放回原位。
OK, are we ready?
OK，我们准备好了吗？
[NERVOUS LAUGHTER] Sure.
[紧张的笑声] 当然。
That was such an ominous laugh.
那是如此不祥的笑声。
The movie opens with the couple, Dan and Franny, getting married in a courthouse, which Will and Rebecca also did. Dan lifts Franny and carries her out. The couple starts out really in love, having lots of sex, laughing, kissing in bed.
电影开场是这对夫妇，丹和弗兰妮，在法院结婚，威尔和瑞贝卡也是这样。丹抱起弗兰妮抱着她走出去。这对夫妇起初真的在恋爱，有很多性爱，大笑，在床上接吻。
Is your rash gone?
你的皮疹好了吗？
Yeah.
好了。
[LAUGHS] Really?
[笑] 真的？
Yeah.
好了。
I never had a rash. There's no rash. I don't know what they're talking about.
我从没得过皮疹。根本没有皮疹。我不知道他们在说什么。
The guy's job in the film? Dog sitter.
那家伙在电影里的工作？狗保姆。
He's quite the rascal, aren't you? He's a good boy.
他真是个调皮鬼，不是吗？他是个乖孩子。
Wait, can I just point out the dog that you're house sitting in this movie is literally the same breed of dog that is sitting under the table right now.
等等，我能指出你在电影里照看的这只狗和此刻坐在桌子下的狗简直是同一个品种吗。
Yeah, it's like a Jack Russell Chihuahua mix that he's dog sitting. And I am also dog sitting a Jack Russell Chihuahua mix.
是啊，就像他在照看的那只杰克罗素梗犬和吉娃娃混种。而我也在照看一只杰克罗素梗犬和吉娃娃混种。
In fact, the house in the film where Dan and Franny do their dog sitting is a lot like the house Will and I are sitting in at this very moment. Similar layout and decor, same view.
事实上，电影里丹和弗兰妮照看狗的房子和威尔和我现在坐的这栋房子很像。类似的布局和装饰，同样的视野。
At least come swimming with me.
至少陪我去游泳。
No, I want to finish this.
不，我想完成这个。
In another scene, Franny is sitting at her computer working on a script. Dan is trying to get her attention.
在另一个场景中，弗兰妮坐在电脑前写剧本。丹试图引起她的注意。
It's just you writing for your dumb job. Come on, swim. Swim.
只是你为你那份愚蠢的工作写东西。快点，游吧。游吧。
Stop.
停。
[SIGHS]
[叹气]
Later.
待会。
The real life version of this would actually play out a little differently-- less fun and more sad. Will says he'd do everything he could to get out of her way when she was working.
现实生活中的这个版本实际上演起来会有点不同——没那么有趣，更悲伤。威尔说他会尽一切努力在她工作时避开她。
I would just disappear. I'd wheel the TV into the bedroom and watch it in there, just so it wouldn't be distracting.
我只会消失。我会把电视推到卧室里在里面看，只是为了不分心。
The movie-- which, I'll admit, I'm the target audience for-- I liked it. Marriage made Franny unhappy in the same way it made me unhappy, like my life had ended. I spent so much time thinking about whether or not I wanted to be with my husband, but I couldn't tell him that. So we had nothing to talk about, because if he asked me what I was thinking, the real answer would have been, I'm not sure if I love you anymore.
这部电影——我承认，我是目标观众——我很喜欢。婚姻让弗兰妮不快乐的方式和我一样，就像我的生活结束了一样。我花了很多时间思考我是否想和我的丈夫在一起，但我没法告诉他。所以我们无话可谈，因为如果他问我在想什么，真正的答案会是，我不确定我还爱不爱你。
The scene that Will feared of Franny confiding in her mom and friends about all her husband's terrible qualities and everyone saying what they really think of him, that never happens. There's no scene where anyone badmouths him, none at all. No one tells anyone to dump the loser. Instead, what happens is much more interesting. Late in the film, Franny sits down to talk to her mom about her marriage. In the scene, she's trying to convince herself to stay with him.
威尔害怕的那场弗兰妮向妈妈和朋友倾诉丈夫的所有可怕品质、大家说出对他真实想法的场景，从来没有发生过。没有场景是任何人说他坏话，根本没有。没有人告诉任何人甩掉这个失败者。相反，发生的事情更有趣。电影后期，弗兰妮坐下来和妈妈谈论她的婚姻。在那一幕里，她试图说服自己留下来。
I'm fine. I'm fine. Everything's fine.
我很好。我很好。一切都很好。
Will sits forward in his seat. The day his marriage fell apart, Will came home and Rebecca was on the couch crying. She said she'd been talking to her mom, but he never knew what their conversation was about. He felt like he was getting to see it now. In the scene, Franny, played by Eve Hewson, talks to her mom, played by Andie MacDowell.
威尔身体前倾。他婚姻破裂的那天，威尔回家发现瑞贝卡在沙发上哭。她说她在和妈妈谈话，但他从不知道谈话内容是什么。他觉得他现在能看到了。在场景里，由伊芙·休森扮演的弗兰妮和由安迪·麦克道威尔扮演的妈妈谈话。
Maybe it's just like the first year of marriage is the hardest, you know, like that old saying? And in a few years, I'll look back on it and laugh.
也许结婚第一年是最难的，你知道，像那句老话说的？再过几年，回头看看它我会笑的。
Baby, look at me. That saying is bull-[BLEEP]. The first year should be your best. If it wasn't, none of us would stick around, because it only gets harder, much harder.
宝贝，看着我。那句话是胡扯。第一年应该是你最好的。如果不是，我们谁也不会留下来，因为它只会变得更难，难得多。
It's-- just, like, seeing how upset she is, that sucks. She felt really bad. This is just a bad feeling for someone to have to go through.
看到她有多难过，太糟糕了。她感觉真的很糟。这对任何人来说都是个坏感觉，不得不经历这些。
You're seeing how hard it was for her.
你看到了她有多难过。
Well, just-- I don't think I was incorrect to focus on my own struggles during the whole process of splitting up. But it did kind of prevent me from thinking about hers as well. I just didn't have as much of an appreciation for the difficulty of it. The misery that goes into that choice. It-- also is a little bit of a relief that it was hard for her. If it had been very easy for her to end things, I would have felt like such absolute trash. If, just one day, she'd come home and been like, you know what? Not for me. Bye, pal.
好吧，只是……在分裂的整个过程中，我认为关注我自己的挣扎并没有错。但这确实阻止了我想象她的挣扎。我对这其中的难度没有那么高的评价。为了那个选择所付出的痛苦。还有一点安慰是，这对她来说也很难。如果结束这一切对她来说很容易，我会觉得自己像个绝对的垃圾。如果某天她回家说，你知道吗？不适合我。再见，伙计。
But that's the story you've kind of been telling yourself.
但那也是你一直对自己说的故事。
Yeah. Yeah.
是啊。是啊。
For years, Will had been telling himself the same version of their breakup, something he'd sandpaper down into this. Rebecca got her big break and then she dumped him out of the blue. He was heartbroken. She was happy and thriving. Moving on was easy for her. But watching this, it came flooding back-- at least a year, maybe more, when Rebecca was sad before their breakup. It was like time traveling through all this pain that he deleted from his memory.
多年来，威尔一直对自己讲述着他们分手的相同版本，他把这磨平成了：瑞贝卡有了重大突破，然后她突然甩了他。他心碎了。她快乐且繁荣。对她来说继续前进很容易。但看着这一切，记忆如潮水般涌回——至少一年，也许更多，瑞贝卡在分手前就很悲伤。这就像穿越回所有他从记忆中删除的痛苦。
We asked Rebecca to come talk about her movie with Will. She met us at the house where Will was house sitting. It's a little awkward. They talk about the weather and traffic. In the six years since their marriage ended, they've never had a conversation about it. And for her, understandably, this did not seem like the best way to begin one, by talking about her movie.
我们邀请瑞贝卡来谈谈她和威尔的电影。她在威尔照看房子的房子里见了我们。有点尴尬。他们聊了天气和交通。在他们婚姻结束后的六年里，他们从未谈论过它。对她来说，可以理解，这不是开始谈话的最佳方式，通过谈论她的电影。
And I mean this in a certain sense-- it has nothing to do with Will. It's its own movie, and it's not a documentary. So I kind of object to the idea that we're going to read into this movie, and we're going to use it as some kind of secret code to understand this real life relationship that existed.
我的意思是，在某种意义上——这和威尔无关。这是它自己的电影，不是纪录片。所以我反对我们阅读这部电影的想法，我们要把它用作某种秘密代码来理解这种现实生活中存在的真实关系。
But also, I feel like the way you're saying, it's like, I just made a movie. It was just a movie. Why are you reading into this movie? But I feel like there are-- it's more specifically related to an experience that you had.
但同时，我觉得你说的方式就像是，我只是拍了一部电影。这只是一部电影。为什么你要阅读这部电影？但我觉得这里面……它更具体地与你经历过的一种经历有关。
Sure, but I'm not the first person to do such a thing.
当然，但我不是第一个做这种事的人。
He had to be a dog walker.
他必须是个遛狗的人。
Well, but I--
嗯，但我——
I said that's why I knew-- I was like, he's going to dog sit and he's going to have no ambition.
我说这就是我为什么知道——我心想，他要照看狗，他会没有野心。
Yeah. I guess I always thought of that character as not someone without ambition, but someone who was afraid. And that's not me looking at you, going like, that's really who you are.
是啊。我总是觉得那个角色不是一个没有野心的人，而是一个恐惧的人。那不是我在看着你，像是，那真是你的样子。
Will tells Rebecca what he told me, how the most emotional part of the movie was seeing her side of things, how hard it was for her to decide to break up, and then to finally do it.
威尔告诉瑞贝卡他告诉我的一切，电影中最感人的部分是看到她的视角，决定分手是多么困难，最后才真正执行。
It felt bad because it was just her trying to justify not ending it or trying to convince herself it'll get better. And that was a very emotional thing for me, and the most affecting part of the movie-- like, hard to watch.
这感觉很糟，因为这只是她在试图证明不结束它是合理的，或者试图说服自己一切都会变好。那对我来说是一件非常感人的事情，也是电影中最感人的部分——就像很难看下去。
Is it because it reminded you of that last sort of big conversation we had that was emotional?
是因为它提醒了你我们那次最后的情绪化的谈话吗？
It felt bad because it reminded me of you having to do yourself kind of all of the recognizing of the problems in the relationship. I just hadn't ever considered the journey to coming to that point in that conclusion, and how difficult it is to do that. That's clear, right? That makes sense?
这感觉很糟，因为这提醒了我你不得不自己去识别关系中的问题。我从来没考虑过得出那个结论的旅程，以及做到这一点是多么困难。很清楚吧？说得通吧？
I think so. I mean, is this now the part of the show where we just talk about our breakup that you want me to respond? Yeah, I mean, I don't really want to get into it, but that was a really tough period. And those were really kind of weirdly dark, confusing times. And I think that's why I wrote this. It wasn't like I was trying to write this so you would understand something. I was doing it so that I could understand something.
我想是吧。我是说，现在是节目中我们只是谈论分手的部分吗，你想让我回应？我是说，我不想卷入其中，但那是一段真的很艰难的时期。那些是真的很怪异的、黑暗的、混乱的时代。我想这就是我写这个的原因。并不是我在试图写这个以便你理解什么。我这样做是为了让我自己理解什么。
I feel like-- so I mean, I obviously relate to this because I'm going through a divorce. I left my husband a year ago. And--
我觉得……我是说，我显然能体会到这一点，因为我正在经历离婚。我一年前离开了我丈夫。而且——
Oh, more personal info-- my marriage seems really similar to theirs. My husband was mostly unemployed. I was the one who was working all the time. Neither of us were happy. And I had to be the one to call it.
哦，更多的个人信息——我的婚姻看起来和他们真的很像。我丈夫基本处于失业状态。我是一直在工作的那个。我们都不快乐。我不得不做出决定的人。
I sort of knew. And I have to say, I wish he would give me credit, you know? It was really awful and hard and heartbreaking, and I was tormented by it. And it was the hardest decision I've ever made. And-- this is my dream realization that my partner could ever have, which is to say, oh, my god, it was hard for you, too. Are you getting that, or am I projecting?
我某种程度上知道。而且我不得不说，我希望他能给我功劳，你知道吗？这真的很糟糕、艰难且心碎，我被它折磨着。这是我做过的最艰难的决定。而且——这是我的伴侣可能实现的梦想，那就是说，哦，天哪，这对你来说也很难。你得到这个了吗，还是我在投射？
No, I mean-- it's just, we've been broken up for how long now?
不，我是说——只是，我们分手多久了？
Over six years.
超过六年。
Yeah, I mean, and I haven't been spending much of that time, thinking, oh, I hope Will understands my perspective someday. I think I've just-- I think it's really nice that maybe there is some kind of mutual middle ground that we're seeing it from. But I think that I've just-- it was OK for me to let Will have his own path through it.
是啊，我是说，而且我没把那么多时间花在思考，哦，我希望威尔有一天能理解我的观点。我想我已经——我想这真的很棒，也许有一些我们正在从它看到的某种共同的中间立场。但我认为我已经——让威尔走他自己的路对他来说是可以的。
Will had a story of how things ended that was cemented in his mind. And without the film, he would have gone on thinking it, cherry-picking the moments that made him feel the worst. Rebecca says if you want your ex to understand your breakup, the best way probably isn't to make a movie about it. It's way too much work and money. And the most likely outcome is that they'll hate you for it.
威尔有一个关于事情如何结束的故事，这在他的脑海中巩固了。没有电影，他会继续那样想，挑挑拣拣那些让他感觉最糟的时刻。瑞贝卡说如果你想让前任理解你的分手，最好的方式可能不是拍一部关于它的电影。这工作量和钱太多了。最可能的结果是他们会为此恨你。
Elna Baker is one of the producers of our show. Since we first aired this story, both Will and Rebecca each have gotten married. Rebecca has a new TV show called Guilty Party on Paramount Plus. And Will has a comedy album out. To find it, look for Will Weldon on Amazon Music.
埃尔娜·贝克是我们节目的制作人之一。自我们第一次播出这个故事以来，威尔和瑞贝卡都已再婚。瑞贝卡在派拉蒙Plus上有一部名为《有罪方》的新剧。威尔有一张喜剧专辑。要找到它，请在亚马逊音乐上查找威尔·威尔登。
Act Four, "The Kid Namastays in the Picture." So our show today is about people who watch a film and then have their own very particular take on it. And not long ago, I learned about somebody like that. Here she is in Harry Potter glasses and a onesie with a Gryffindor crest on it, giving her version of the first Harry Potter film.
第四幕，“孩子在画面里”。所以我们今天的节目是关于观看某部电影然后有自己非常独特看法的人。不久前，我认识了这样一个人。这是她穿着哈利波特眼镜和印有格兰芬多徽章的连体衣，给出她对第一部哈利波特电影的版本。
We meet Harry, aged 10, living in a house. Coming up to stand, take your feet wide, arms out and above your head, house pose. Harry lives at Number 4 Privet Drive.
我们遇到了10岁的哈利，住在一所房子里。站起来，双脚分开，双臂伸向头顶，房子姿势。哈利住在女贞路4号。
This is Jaime Amor, the host or, I guess, yoga instructor, of a series of videos called Cosmic Kids Yoga. Viewership of these videos skyrocketed during quarantine from about 100,000 viewers a day to about a million. And a lot of her most popular videos for kids are her retelling the stories of children's movies-- Moana or Trolls or Star Wars-- and combining the stories with yoga.
这是杰米·阿莫尔，她是一系列名为“宇宙儿童瑜伽”视频的主持人，或者我想说是瑜伽教练。这些视频的观看量在隔离期间从每天约10万增长到约100万。而她最受欢迎的许多儿童视频是她重述儿童电影的故事——莫阿娜、巨魔或星球大战——并将故事与瑜伽结合。
Back when we first aired today's program at the height of the quarantine, I watched a six-year-old regularly and very happily do yoga for a half hour with these YouTube videos before starting his day of remote learning first grade. I would walk by and I would just get totally caught up in these videos.
回到我们第一次播出今天的节目时，在隔离期的高峰，我定期看一个六岁的孩子在YouTube视频中非常快乐地做半小时瑜伽，然后再开始他的远程学习一年级的一天。我会走过，我会被这些视频完全吸引。
And I have to say, a lot of my pleasure and complete fascination with them was seeing the ingenuity that Jaime Amor uses to incorporate the poses into the storytelling. Like, for example, warrior pose for Elsa, making snow and ice in Frozen. Forward bends as Alice in Wonderland leans over to take a drink from the bottle that says "drink me" on it. In The Wizard of Oz, when the tornado arrives, Dorothy is on her bed, in bed pose, of course.
我必须说，我从中获得的很多乐趣和完全着迷是看到杰米·阿莫尔将姿势纳入叙事的独创性。比如，战士姿势代表艾莎，在《冰雪奇缘》中制造雪和冰。前弯姿势代表爱丽丝梦游仙境，弯腰去拿写着“喝我”的瓶子喝一口。在《绿野仙踪》中，当龙卷风到来时，多萝西在床上，当然是床姿势。
Look out the window. There's that mean lady from the village. She's riding a bicycle in the sky. Lying on your backs, criss cross your fingers.
往窗外看。那是村里那个刻薄的女人。她在天空中骑自行车。平躺在背上，手指交叉。
Bicycle pose, of course. Pada Sanchalanasana.
当然是自行车姿势。
Lift up your legs and pedal your legs like you're riding a bicycle. She's cackling like a witch. [CACKLES] But she's not riding a bicycle anymore. She's on a broomstick with a black hat. She really is a witch. Coming into broomstick pose, lying on your tummies, everyone.
抬起腿，像骑自行车一样踩踏。她像女巫一样咯咯笑。[咯咯笑] 但她不再骑自行车了。她坐在扫帚上，戴着黑帽子。她真的是个女巫。进入扫帚姿势，趴在肚子上，每个人。
This is locust pose, Salabhasana.
这是蝗虫姿势。
Take your arms down by your side, and lift your feet and chest up at the same time, going, whoosh!
把双臂放在身体两侧，同时抬起双脚和胸部，发出“呼”的声音！
The videos are actually structured like a real yoga class, always starting with a sitting pose and namaste, and always ending with shavasana, resting pose.
这些视频实际上结构就像一节真正的瑜伽课，总是从坐姿和合十礼开始，总是以休息姿势结束。
Lying all the way down.
一直躺下。
And each of the videos plays a little half-hour yoga appreciation of movie, though they're all kid's films, so Jaime Amor's kid-friendly tone matches them perfectly. But putting together today's program, we wondered what it would be like if she took on a film that's made for grownups and beloved by grownups, not by kids. So we reached out to her and her husband, Martin, who makes these videos with her. And they were into it. And we considered a bunch of different films to turn into yoga-- Silence of the Lambs and Pulp Fiction and Parasite, before we settled on this film. Jaime Amor prepared this for us.
每个视频都播放半小时对电影的瑜伽欣赏，尽管它们都是儿童电影，所以杰米·阿莫尔的儿童友好语气非常匹配。但在制作今天的节目时，我们想如果她接手一部为成年人制作且受成年人喜爱的电影会怎样，而不是孩子。所以我们联系了她和她的丈夫马丁，他和她一起制作这些视频。他们很感兴趣。我们考虑了一堆不同的电影转成瑜伽——《沉默的羔羊》、《低俗小说》和《寄生虫》，最终选定了这部电影。杰米·阿莫尔为我们准备了这个。
Thelma and Louise are best friends. Let's do a hug pose, wrapping our arms around our shoulders, like we're hugging our best friend. They set out for a weekend away in the mountains to take a break. On the way, they stop for a cold, refreshing drink at a bar. Thelma dances with a man called Harlan. Coming into our dancer pose, standing on one leg, we catch our foot with our hand behind us, and lift it as we reach forwards with our other arm.
塞尔玛和路易丝是好朋友。让我们做一个拥抱姿势，双臂环抱肩头，就像我们拥抱着最好的朋友。他们出发去山里度假休息。路上，他们在酒吧停下来喝杯冰凉清爽的饮料。塞尔玛和一个叫哈兰的男人跳舞。进入我们的舞者姿势，单脚站立，我们用手抓住背后的脚，并在另一只手伸向前时抬起它。
Harlan wants to do more than dancing with Thelma, but she doesn't want to. Louise finds them and is so angry at Harlan that she shoots him in the chest. Coming into our shooter warrior pose, standing one foot forward, one foot back, we bend our front knee and open our arms wide. Pow! Thelma and Louise whiz off in the car. Coming into car pose, sitting with legs out long, arms forward to hold the steering wheel. Oh, dear. What have they done?
哈兰想做的不仅是和塞尔玛跳舞，但她不想。路易丝发现了他们，对哈兰非常生气，于是向他的胸口开了一枪。进入我们的射手战士姿势，一只脚在前，一只脚在后，我们弯曲前膝并将双臂张开。砰！塞尔玛和路易丝开车疾驰而去。进入我们的汽车姿势，双腿伸长坐着，双臂向前握住方向盘。哦，天哪。他们做了什么？
On the road, the women meet a handsome, friendly young man called JD. Thelma rather likes JD and invites him for a sleepover. In the morning, JD wakes up. Coming up to stand, reaching our arms up to the sky, we wave and say, hello, sun. And while Thelma and Louise go to breakfast, JD steals all of Louise's money. Oh, dear. Thelma feels really bad. To fix the situation, Thelma decides to become a robber and steal all the money from a nearby market. Naughty Thelma. Now the police are after them.
路上，女人们遇到了一个英俊、友好的年轻人，叫JD。塞尔玛挺喜欢JD，邀请他过夜。早晨，JD醒了。站起来，手臂伸向天空，我们挥手说，你好，太阳。当塞尔玛和路易丝去吃早餐时，JD偷走了路易丝所有的钱。哦，天哪。塞尔玛感觉很糟。为了解决这个问题，塞尔玛决定成为强盗，从附近的集市偷走所有的钱。淘气的塞尔玛。现在警察在追他们。
Thelma and Louise arrive at the Grand Canyon. Coming to stand in our mountain pose, standing with our feet hip distance, arms by our side, we become as still and strong as the mountains. They take a breath together, soaking up the incredible view and the peace of this place. All of a sudden, a helicopter thunders into view. Jumping our feet wide and clapping our hands up over our heads. The dust swirls and the sirens scream. Arms wide, we spin, side to side to side. They're trapped.
塞尔玛和路易丝到达了大峡谷。用山峰姿势站立，双脚与臀部同宽，双臂放在身体两侧，我们变得像山一样静止和强大。他们一起呼吸，沉浸在这难以置信的景色和这个地方的宁静中。突然，一架直升机轰隆隆出现在视野中。双脚跳开，双手拍在头顶。尘土飞扬，警笛尖叫。双臂张开，我们旋转，左右旋转。他们被困住了。
Thelma looks at her best friend. Listen, let's not get caught. Let's keep going. Louise checks if Thelma is sure. She nods. Louise cups Thelma's face and kisses her, cupping our faces to feel our cheeks. Louise steps on the gas, stepping one foot forward. As the car screeches forward, Thelma and Louise clasp hands. The car flies off the cliff. Coming into our flying pose, lifting up our back leg, balancing on our standing leg, and taking our arms out wide, we're flying!
塞尔玛看着她最好的朋友。听着，我们别被抓住了。让我们继续。路易丝检查塞尔玛是否确定。她点头。路易丝捧着塞尔玛的脸亲吻她，捧着我们的脸来感受脸颊。路易丝踩下油门，一只脚向前踏步。当汽车发出尖锐声向前冲时，塞尔玛和路易丝紧握双手。汽车飞下了悬崖。进入我们的飞行姿势，抬起后腿，在支撑腿上保持平衡，并将双臂张开，我们正在飞！
After all that action, we're ready to relax now. So we lie down and let our bodies feel heavy. We close our eyes, and take a big deep breath.
经历这一切行动后，我们现在准备放松了。所以我们躺下，让身体感到沉重。闭上眼睛，深呼吸。
[INHALES] [EXHALES]
[吸气] [呼气]
Jaime Amor, her yoga videos for kids that mix movies and yoga, but also there are ones which mix video games and yoga and all kinds of other things, are at cosmickids.com. Or find their free YouTube channel, youtube.com/cosmickidsyoga.
杰米·阿莫尔，她混合了电影和瑜伽的儿童瑜伽视频，还有混合了电子游戏和瑜伽以及各种其他东西的视频，都在cosmickids.com上。或者找到他们免费的YouTube频道，youtube.com/cosmickidsyoga。
[MUSIC - "LET'S GO TO THE MOVIES" BY AILEEN QUINN]
[音乐 - “我们去看电影” - 艾琳·奎因]
Well, our program was produced today by Lina Misitzis and Noor Gill. The people who put together today's show includes Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Damien Graef, Michelle Harris, Chana Joffe-Walt, Seth Lind, Stowe Nelson, Nadia Reiman, Alyssa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Production help on today's rerun came from Chloe Weiner.
好了，我们的节目今天由莉娜·米西齐斯和努尔·吉尔制作。今天节目的制作人员包括埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、达米安·格拉夫、米歇尔·哈里斯、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、塞斯·林德、斯托·尼尔森、纳迪亚·雷曼、艾丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和戴安·吴。今天重播的制作帮助来自克洛伊·维纳。
Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Jason Smart, David Selassie, Hong Yan, Xiangqian Wu, Karina Longworth, BA Parker, Adrian Shirk, Paul Scheer, Luke, Sophie, and Olivia, and Cecil Ranieri.
我们的执行编辑是莎拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。我们的执行编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。今天特别感谢杰森·斯马特、戴维·塞拉西、洪雁、向前吴、卡琳娜·朗沃思、BA·帕克、阿德里安·舍克、保罗·谢尔、卢克、索菲和奥利维亚，以及塞西尔·拉涅利。
Our website, where you can listen to any of our over 750 shows for absolutely free, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. He recently did 23andMe. Torey had never wondered who his father was and then got some surprising news.
我们的网站，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过750期的节目，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX公共广播交易发送到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生。他最近做了23andMe。托里从未想过他的父亲是谁，然后得到了一些令人惊讶的消息。
It's the mailman!
是邮差！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "LET'S GO TO THE MOVIES" BY AILEEN QUINN]
[音乐 - “我们去看电影” - 艾琳·奎因]